This is Lilly, also known as Superžena on YouTube. And as a female member
she experiences her menstruation every month. You know, when I first got my period
I had no idea what was going on. I went to the laundry, tra la la la, undressed my underwear
and I said, "What is it?". Because I didn't talk to anyone about it, so I was concerned.
My mind was ruby. "Did I fall on my bike today?" I didn't have a couple what was happening.
I'm sure most girls will go through the way you hate it, but you can't look elsewhere.
So I thought, "I'm dying, I'm dying." What you may or may not realize
is that every time a woman is menstruated, it is because her body is preparing
to get pregnant and have a baby. Do you know what keeps our species?
Yes. Every month the female body goes through incredibly complex and fascinating
transformation called the menstrual cycle. It all starts in the ovaries that everyone contains
over 100,000 eggs. Once a month one egg is released which takes about 3 days
the way to the uterus and during the journey, the uterus begins to form the lining
which is rich in nutrients and everything necessary to create life. Under certain circumstances,
sperm fertilizes the egg and starts pregnancy in the uterus. However, before this, female
the ovaries increase the production of estrogen and progesterone hormones and these hormones
support and maintain a certain lining. But hormones also enter
into the blood and travel through the whole body including the brain. It's obvious that
and progesterone tends to collide with other chemical linkers in the brain
called neurotransmitters. And this can lead to a known premenstration syndrome or
also called PMS. "WHY is MENSTRUACE so FUCKING ?!" ... science.
So here are the different substances in my brain and they're all completely deranged, playing with my mind every month.
I mean, science plays with me with my consciousness. I'm annoying and anxious, and that's what I am
she hadn't even started menstruating. Which brings interesting knowledge: PMS is not the same
like menstruation, which is probably one of the greatest myths ever. It actually starts
7-14 days before the girl has any signs of bleeding. This is because the levels of estrogen and progesterone
as they build the lining they rise. About 50-80% of women have experienced
some degree of physical or psychic symptoms of PMS, but many are not even aware of it.
PMS may occur before menstruation itself, but the present time keeps myths
that it is the menstruation that causes these hormonal changes. PMS can
manifest as a psychological symptom such as mood changes. I hate you so much
But at the same time, you are the cutest, but I want to kill you. Rage. Cry.
Irritability. It's alright. It's alright. It's alright. It's alright. It's alright. Or as psychic symptoms
such as abdominal pain, insomnia, nausea. One woman's PMS is not the same as other women,
which is why professional medical workers have difficulty finding a clear and obvious understanding of how it all works
works. Other psychological changes also appear. Amygdala in the brain that controls
emotion, increasing its activity. We also observed lower levels of well-felt serotonin
and gaba neurotransmitters that have anti-anxiety effects, causing stress and anxiety to increase.
Oh, okay, so, you're wondering why I feel like this when all these things happen
in my body? Because I can become a big poison and I can't control it. It's like:
"I want to kiss you, but I don't want you to touch me." Because you're pretty looking, etc,
but I also hate you. And I want the mountains of chocolate. And here I think about it
maybe I have a bad day, or I'm crazy because it doesn't happen
at the same time as my menstruation. But no, it could just be a PMS. But when menstruation
begins, these hormone levels fall rapidly. If there is no fertilization,
estrogen and progesterone levels decrease and the body becomes aware that nothing is happening.
And as a result, a layer that has formed for a potential fetus begins to fall.
And this sloughing of the membrane and the mucosa cannot go anywhere but out, which of course does
also your hooks. But this is what happens when a really funny part starts.
Because even if there is not the same amount of hormones moving in my brain, I have to spit out the unused
Mucous membrane and blood from my body. Actually, it's fun because it causes it
convulsions and bloating, and the wonderful need to go out but not to be able to do so.
Of course, when it ends, the cycle starts again all over again and the cycle that is needed
to maintain our human species. So when I don't have my day, dude, you know,
I'm doing it for humanity. Because there are only a few fixed cycles in the world.
The sun rises and sets. high tide and low tide. And my menstruation. So do it. Fact.
The woman is super okay? We'll be giving autographs all night. Really. Without
a permanent menstrual cycle, our existence of humanity
would disappear completely. So even though this event may cause these mood changes,
so it's definitely worth it. So thank you to the women for dealing
with PMS and menstruation. We owe you one for this. Don't forget to visit this amazing
Lill's YouTube channel iiSuperwomanii, for more stunning videos. Really, she's one
of the funniest people on YouTube. We add a link below the video. And give us a subscription
for more science videos every week. No, but really, you can really get mad
if you have menstruation. If you don't believe me, this is a self-portrait I did
when I had menstruation. Nice.